wer sind die flüchtlinge vom grenzzaun
die die gerade rein wollen nach europa
die lukaschenko dorthin geschleust hat
und die notfalls gewaltsam den grenzzaun
knacken dort grenzgebiet von belarus
nach polen wo es in den letzten stunden
waren schüsse gab wo sich soldaten
beider seiten inzwischen auge in auge
gegenüberstehen mittendrin eben hunderte
flüchtlinge wer sind sie woher kommen
sie unsere reporter stellen jetzt diese
menschen einmal vor ja wo verpflichten
sie investiere geschichte unserer
reporter peter wilke hat flüchtlinge in
die ahl stock getroffen unweit der
grenze ist uns jetzt auch zugeschaltet
hallo peter was konnten gehe die
menschen berichten
ja hallo patricia genau wir waren
gestern abend ihren dialog in einer
flüchtlingsunterkunft das ist sozusagen
die zweite stelle wo die flüchtlinge
dann hier in polen ankommen wenn sie
nicht zurück gepusht werden die erste
stelle ist eine art erstaufnahmelager
und dort wird dann geschaut schon von
den soldaten
ob diese flüchtlinge überhaupt die
chance auf einen asyl aufenthalt haben
oder eben nicht also ob sie überhaupt
asyl bekommen können oder nicht und dann
wenn diese chance besteht werden sie
eben in dieser unterkunft gebracht wenn
nicht werden sie ja so muss man es sagen
zumindestens laut eu recht illegal
wieder zurück gepusht nach belarus ja
und wir konnten gestern in dieser zeit
unterkunft an ihren wir dass dort mit
zwei sprechen der eine mit dem wir
gesprochen haben mohammed kommt aus dem
irak und was der uns erzählt hat da
können wir einmal kurz rein
hat wird man ich wurde im irak von
milizen festgehalten und eingeschüchtert
sie wollten mich töten ich wollte
fliehen aber habe kein visum in meiner
heimat hatte ich steh auf der straße
verkauft aber sogar das nahmen sie mehr
weg sie sind mein zuhause marschiert und
haben uns gesagt dass wir verschwinden
sollen ich musste mit meiner familie
fliehen um meine frau und meine kinder
zu schützen
ich kann nicht zurück in den irak er
will ich vorher sterben als dass ich
mich dort umbringen lassen
ja wir haben es gehört wirklich schlimme
sachen die moment da aus seiner heimat
im irak erzählt er ist ebenso nied und
wird von schiitischen milizen dort
verfolgt und ist jetzt eben diesen
schlimmen weg über belarus diesen
gefährlichen weg mit seiner familie mit
seinen drei kindern und seiner frau die
schwanger ist gegangen und wohnt jetzt
eben in dieser unterkunft möchte aber
eigentlich weiter nach deutschland ja
und dann haben wir eben noch mit dem
anderen herren in dem video gesprochen
das war update mut aus syrien und was
der uns erzählt hat das können wir uns
auch einmal kurz an
die situation und das leben in syrien
insgesamt sind schrecklich die folgen
des krieges sind untragbar
es ist nicht möglich dort zu leben
außerdem wurde ich gezwungen und haas
hat für die armee dazu dienen das wollte
ich nicht deshalb bin ich geflohen
ja wir haben es gehört abtrieb ist davor
geflohen für diese schlimme armee dienst
müssen er hat selber noch familie in
syrien die dort noch leben eine frau und
vier kinder die sind eben noch da die
möchte er wahrscheinlich dann auch
nachholen wenn es nach deutschland
geschafft hat dort möchte er nämlich hin
er hat uns auch fotos aus seiner heimat
in syrien gezeigt er hat dort als fahrer
gearbeitet hat eigentlich ein relativ
glückliches leben geführt wie haben
ihnen viel lächeln gesehen immer hat
seine arbeit spaß gemacht dort auf den
feldern dort hat er uns auch dann schon
ein bisschen stolz und lustig berichtet
dass dort dann auch erde aus deutschland
angekommen ist dort hat er dann
sozusagen jetzt sein traumziel
deutschland schon über diese blumenerde
die dort benutzt wurde ein bisschen ein
bisschen kennen gelernt ein bisschen
kontakt aufgebaut ja und jetzt hängt er
sozusagen ihren polen fest möchte
eigentlich nach deutschland weiter und
was dieser krieg auch mit ihm gemacht
hat das hat er uns auch sehr
eindrücklich gezeigt er hat uns nämlich
die namen gezeigt die ihr aus diesem
krieg getragen hat die sollten wir jetzt
auch sehen können also er war das schwer
gezeichnet von dem krieg in syrien hat
schlimmes erlebt und wollte jetzt eben
weiter nach deutschland um dort eine
sichere heimat viel zu können
dass sie lernen wollen tausende andere
die dort gerade in den wäldern ausharren
am zaun aus haren peter wilke und
zugeschaltet als aus polen vielen
herzlichen dank für dieses gespräch